we're going to take a look at this
vertical resisted motion question
together because
it has a couple of cool little things
that i want you to take notice of
which are different from vertical
resisted motion questions we've looked
at in the past so let's read it together
an object of mass 100 kilograms is found
to experience a resistant
force in newtons of one tenth of the
square
of its velocity okay so let's pause
right there
that phrase that you just read the
resistive force in newtons of
one tenth the square of its velocity
is the first place where i want you to
pause um there's two key differences
here to what we've had a look at
previously number one we think about
resistive force things like air
resistance aerodynamic drag
we always know that these are in
proportion to
something related to the velocity
because the faster you're going the more
drag you are
experiencing however we've seen so far
examples where
it's simply you know one-tenth or
one-fifth or one
some other constant proportion of just
the velocity
on its own here it's not just the
velocity it's the square
of its velocity so when we have a think
about the differential equation
that's going to come out of this it's
not just going to be a v it's going to
be a
v squared that we need to think about so
there's the first factor
and then the second thing is if you
think back to how we introduced
uh vertical resisted motion and we were
talking about the difference between
upward and downward
journeys one of the things that i
mentioned is that typically
we think about force as having mass
included right and then to get to
acceleration because
force equals mass times acceleration we
just divide through by mass
and so a typical situation like this you
can see this is an um
this is an object that is falling from
rest under gravity so we're considering
a downward journey or we will be
shortly we would normally think okay
well you've got your
uh weight force mass times gravity and
then you also have this other resistive
force that comes from air or water or
whatever medium you're traveling through
and it might have been mkv in this case
because the square of the velocity you
might expect it's an mkv
squared however i just want you to look
back at this sentence again and read it
carefully with me
notice it says you've got this object of
mass 100 kilograms
the resistive force that it experiences
in newtons is
1 10 the square of its velocity
one tenth the square of its velocity do
you notice there's no reference there to
the mass
of the object we knew that the mass is
100 kilograms
but the resistive force is one-tenth the
square of its velocity and doesn't seem
to care
about the mass so this is important
because it means that while these are
sort of very frequently
encountered equations for vertical
resisted motion
up and down they're not the only kind
right as i've just mentioned
it might not be v squared it might be v
and in this case let's choose the right
color here
in this case mass isn't going to figure
into
our consideration for the velocity
squared it's actually going to be that
resistive force will not have an m
term in it at all so those are two
differences
and as we go through the rest of the
question it's going to seem familiar but
if you don't start off with the right
equation setup obviously everything is
going to you know even
no matter how good you're working is
you're going to be heading in the wrong
direction mostly
so now that we've set that up let's see
what we can make of
the rest of the question it says as you
mentioned before
it's falling from rest under gravity so
it's that downward journey we're talking
about
and i'm going to take gravity with this
particular value here 9.8 meters per
second per second
all right now what do we need to ask
part a
show that its terminal velocity is about
99 meters
per second okay what does that mean
terminal velocity well it's exactly what
it says on the tin it's the velocity
that you're ending on terminalize and
terminate or finish
so the idea here is that when the object
falls from rest
initially it has a velocity of zero
but it speeds up gravity starts to
accelerate it downwards
but at some point the acceleration
downwards
is uh or rather the force downwards from
gravity
is matched by the force upwards from air
resistance you're traveling
fast enough that you're experiencing
more and more air resistance and that
air resistance
will rise up to a place or will increase
to a place where it equals or it
balances out
with the force of gravity that's going
downwards so when your
upward force from resistance equals your
downward force from gravity those two
forces the resultant force or net force
will be zero and we will reach our
terminal velocity you'll stop speeding
up
because gravity is not enough of a force
anymore to overcome
the air resistance so therefore what we
want to show is that that terminal
velocity is about
99 meters per second so how do we get
there
well as we kind of alluded to before
we're going to need to start with
an equation that relates our forces to
the different
values that we have within the question
so i'm going to say to begin with
that the uh would help if i wrote rather
than add a laser pointer the force is
going to be equal to
the sum of all the forces acting on me
which is going to be gravity
which we've mentioned already i've got a
particular value for m and a particular
value for g that i'm going to substitute
in
shortly and then i'm going to be you
know if i think about
downward as this positive value here um
just as i
mentioned before if you've got a
downward journey think of down as
positive
the resistive force is against you right
so that's why it's a negative
and that proportion there which i'm
going to put in there from from this
value up here in a second
is in proportion to the square of its
velocity so this is where my equation
begins
and now what i can do is i can start to
fill in the actual numbers that the
question provided me so
my mass was 100 i had a gravity
of 9.8 meters per second per second the
k value that i got given was a tenth
so therefore it's going to be v squared
over 10.
there is my force and of course it
varies according to the velocity that
i'm traveling at
okay now remember what i was saying
before that you've got this kind of
downward force from gravity and then you
have this
upward force from um the
resistive uh force that you experience
from your medium right
now what i want is for these two exactly
to balance out because then you're not
accelerating back down to the ground
anymore uh you're going to just be you
know
traveling at whatever speed you're going
and you're going to be at a constant
velocity or at least you're getting
closer and closer to that right
so in other words what i want for these
to do is to exactly
cancel with each other how would i say
that the force
should be approaching zero right because
these two when you add them together
should be sort of balancing and
cancelling each other out so i'm going
to write that down right terminal
velocity oopsie daisy
terminal velocity
occurs as the force approaches zero
okay so i've got my force equation just
up here
right there so i'm going to write that
out and see if i can solve
for v that will give me my terminal
velocity
so i've got uh i guess that's 980 oopsie
daisy on the left hand side
minus v squared on 10.
that's equal to zero i'm going to let's
see
i will uh add v squared on 10 to both
sides and pop this on the
left hand side so that gives me this v
squared multiplying through by 10 gives
me
800 and v is going to be the square root
of 9800 which i've already chucked into
my calculator and it's something like
98.99
etc a lot of things which are going to
round up so in other words
i've got a velocity a terminal velocity
i should say
of about 99 meters per second
so before we go any further let's just
remember how we did that we set up our
equation here our force equation
and then we just said well your terminal
velocity once you reach that
you're not going to be speeding up or
slowing down so that force should be
getting closer and closer to 0. so i've
just solved for v
when the force equation gives me 0 on
one side
and then this is just algebra from here
probably worth noting
that in this frame of reference it's
just a downward journey
so that's why i'm only considering the
positive value for v when i take the
square root
of both sides